SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THERE IS
DENYING AN EXCLUSIVE REPORT FROM
THE ANGLE AND DOUBLING DOWN ON
THEIR INSISTENCE THAT THEY DID
NOTHING WRONG.
BUT FIRST, TRUMP BUSTS THE
TYRANNY OF THE EXPERT CLASS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE EXPERTS HAVE BEEN WRONG ON
SO MANY THINGS OVER THE LAST
THREE DECADES.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THEY'VE BEEN WRONG ON CHINA,
THEY WERE WRONG ON THE IRAQ WAR,
THEY WERE WRONG ON LIBYA, WRONG
ON IMMIGRATION AND DEAD WRONG ON
TRADE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PROMISED TO
SHAKE UP THE SYSTEM ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHICH HE
REPEATED TODAY.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS BEEN
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF BY OTHER
COUNTRIES, BOTH FRIENDLY AND NOT
SO FRIENDLY, FOR MANY, MANY
DECADES.
I'M HERE TO PROTECT -- AND ONE
OF THE REASONS I WAS ELECTED AS
I'M PROTECTING OUR WORKERS AND
OUR COMPANIES AND I'M NOT GOING
TO LET THAT HAPPEN.
>> Laura: WHAT DOES THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT SPEC AFTER HE GOT
ELECTED?
THAT SOMEHOW DONALD TRUMP WOULD
BECOME LIKE ONE OF THEM?
TRUMP WON BY DEFYING THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND HE HAS
CONTINUED TO DO JUST THAT.
DONALD TRUMP, AND POLITICS, IS
AN INNOVATOR, AND HE'S NOT
AFRAID TO BREAK WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENTS ORTHODOXY TO DO
WHAT HE THINKS IN HIS BEST
JUDGMENT IS THE RIGHT THING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT HIS OWN PARTY'S BARELY
UNIMAGINATIVE OLD GUARD IS
RUNNING TO THE SAME FAILED IDEAS
OF THE PAST THAT GOT US INTO THE
DITCH WE ARE IN AND AT THE SAME
TIME, THE LEFT IS MOVING TO THE
EXTREME AND I WOULD SAY TO THE
EXTREME IRRELEVANCE.
NOW JUST LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT'S
DEMOCRATS ASKED FOR AMNESTY FOR
800,000 DREAMERS.
OKAY.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T ACTUALLY TRY
TO MEET THEM HALFWAY, HE
ACTUALLY WENT TOWARD THEM.
HE RAISED THEM A MILLION, AS AN
AMNESTY FOR 1.8 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
I WASN'T WILD ABOUT THAT OFFER,
FRANKLY, BUT IT DID SHOW
DONALD TRUMP'S WILLINGNESS TO
COMPROMISE AND FRANKLY TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS HAD TO DO WAS
AGREE TO BORDER SECURITY AND A
WALL AND OF COURSE TO END THE
ABSURD POLICY OF CHAIN
MIGRATION.
TO SAVE THE DACA PEOPLE, WHO CAN
REFUSE THAT DEAL?
WHILE, THE ANSWER IS THE
DEMOCRATS COULD, BECAUSE IT
WOULD HAVE GIVEN DONALD TRUMP A
WIN AND DEPRIVED DEMOCRATS OF A
CRUCIAL CAMPAIGN ISSUE.
WELL, NOW THE DREAMERS WHO HAVE
BEEN CYNICALLY USED BY THE
DEMOCRATS ARE BEGINNING TO CATCH
ON.
>> Laura: THOSE DREAMERS ON
CAPITOL HILL AND THEIR
SUPPORTERS YESTERDAY WERE
WHO KNOWS?
MAYBE THEY ARE TIRED OF BEING
PAWNS.
LET'S MOVE TO NORTH KOREA.
EVERY TIME DONALD TRUMP ISSUED A
STATEMENT AGAINST ROCKET MAN OR
DROPPED THE SANCTION ON THE
REGIME, THE EXPERTS PREDICTED AN
APOCALYPSE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DISCOVERED ABOUT THIS NEW
PRESIDENT IS HE HAS NO CLUE
ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH FOREIGN
MATTERS.
HE'S DANGEROUS AND HE SHOULD NOT
BE TALKING WITH THIS KIND OF
BLUSTER.
>> THIS IS A MESS THAT
NORTH KOREA HAS CREATED BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH.
>> HE'S DOING NONE OF THE THINGS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE A REAL
DIPLOMATIC BREAKTHROUGH ON
NORTH KOREA.
>> Laura: INSTEAD OF THEIR
PROMISED APOCALYPSE, WE HAVE
WORD TODAY THAT THE PRESIDENT --
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT   R
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT   S
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT   D
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT   N
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT   I
I LIKE TO CALL HIM PRESIDENT   M
JON-CABBAGE PATCH DOLL.
NORTH KOREA IS SIGNALING A
WILLINGNESS TO HOLD TALKS WITH
THE UNITED STATES AND
CONSIDERING AT LEAST GIVING UP
THEIR NUKES.
YOU THINK THAT THAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT TRUMP'S TOUGH
TALK AND REITERATING THAT ALL
OPTIONS WERE ON THE TABLE?
NEVER.
SO MUCH FOR THE EXPERTS.
AFTER DECADES OF BAD TRADE
DEALS -- LET'S MOVE ONTO ANOTHER
TOPIC, THE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TRADE DEFICITS,
DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT!
HE'S TRYING TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD, TO COUNTER YEARS OF
UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICES WHEN IT
COMES TO STEAL AND ALUMINUM, ALL
THAT DUMPING WAS GOING ON.
ALL THE GLUTTONS DEAL IN
ALUMINUM.
HE HAS PROPOSED TARIFFS ON BOTH
STEEL AND ALUMINUM IMPORTS.
>> ARE STEEL INDUSTRY IT'S A
FRACTION OF WHAT IT ONCE WAS AND
WE CAN'T LOSE OUR ALUMINUM
INDUSTRY.
ALSO A FRACTION OF WHAT IT ONCE
WAS.
>> Laura: WHILE, THE
ESTABLISHMENT IS IN FULL REVOLT.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN
AMONG REPUBLICAN SENATORS THAT
THIS COULD SORT OF METASTASIZE
INTO A LARGER TRADE WAR.
>> WITH HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS, HE
KNOWS OUR VIEW.
EVERY NOW AND THEN WE ARE JUST
GOING TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH ON HOW WE SHOULD TACKLE
THESE PROBLEMS.
BUT IT SHOULD BE ACKNOWLEDGED
THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED HERE.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S DONE IN A PRUDENT WAY THAT
IS MORE SURGICAL SO WE CAN LIMIT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND,
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
DRIVE THROUGH TOLEDO, AKRON, OR
THE REST OF THE RUST BELT.
YOU WILL SEE GHOST TOWNS, YOU
WILL SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE THAT, GUESS WHAT, THE
GOVERNMENT ABANDONED THEM.
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING GUTTED.
PEOPLE WHO FEEL HOPELESS, AND
YOU BET THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS.
THEY DIDN'T FEEL LIKE TO HAVE
MUCH OPTION, DID THEY?
NO MATTER THE FALLOUT, THE
ESTABLISHMENT WILL ALWAYS LEAN
TOWARD UNFETTERED, UNCHECKED
GLOBAL TRADE.
WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC ADVISOR
GARY COHEN, HE TRIED TO CONVINCE
THE PRESIDENT TO DROP HIS TARIFF
IDEA TO BACK DOWN.
>> I LIKE CONFLICT.
I LIKE HAVING TWO PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW AND I
CERTAINLY HAVE THAT.
AND THEN I MAKE A DECISION.
BUT I LIKE WATCHING IT, I LIKE
SEEING IT AND I THINK IT'S THE
BEST WAY TO GO.
LIKE DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW.
>> Laura: THEY BATTLED IT OUT
IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
GARY: ARGUED ONE POINT, NO
TARIFFS.
AND OTHER PEOPLE, BOB LIE
HEISER, WILBUR
ROSS, THEY WENT FOR THE ECONOMIC
NATIONALIST POINT OF VIEW.
GARY COHN'S WORLDVIEW LOST OUT.
AT THE POPULIST VISION THAT WON
DONALD TRUMP THE ELECTION WON
THE DAY.
THIS MAY HAVE BEEN BREWING FOR A
LONG TIME WITH GARY COHN, AND
LET'S FACE IT, WORKING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, GETTING HAMMERED IN
THE MEDIA FOR YOUR EVERY MOVE,
IT TAKES ITS TOLL, IT'S NOT
EASY.
BUT FROM AN OUTSIDERS
PERSPECTIVE, IT CERTAINLY LOOKS
LIKE GARY COHN PICKED UP HIS
MARBLES AND WENT BACK TO
GOLDMAN SACHS.
WE CANNOT STAND BY IDLY WHILE
CHINA FLOODS OUR COUNTRY WITH
CHEAP STEEL AND DOMINATES THE
GLOBAL MARKET.
ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
IN 2000, THAT WAS BEFORE THEY
BECAME A MEMBER OF THE WTO,
CHINA ACCOUNTED FOR 15% OF
GLOBAL STEELMAKING CAPACITY.
BY 2016 CHINA HAD ALMOST
QUINTUPLED ITS SHARE TO NEARLY
49%.
DOES ANYONE THINK FOR A MINUTE
ANY OF THE EXPERTS THINK ABOUT
WHERE CHINA WILL BE BY 2025 IN
STEELMAKING?
CONSIDER THE NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT.
IF YOU THINK THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO MAKE OUR TANKS AND DESTROYERS
IN A GLOBAL CONFLICT FOR US?
THE TROUBLING THING IS THAT WHEN
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS WRONG, AS
THEY HAVE BEEN ON CHINA, TAX
CUTS, THE ILLEGAL INVASION OF
OUR COUNTRY, THEY STILL LACK THE
HUMILITY TO ADMIT THEY WERE
WRONG.
NATIONAL JOURNAL REPORTING TODAY
THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH
COMPARED HIS ADMINISTRATION TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BUSH SAID, SORT OF MAKES ME LOOK
PRETTY GOOD, DOESN'T IT?
WELL, ACTUALLY IT DOESN'T AND
LESS WAR, A FINANCIAL CRISIS,
UNCHECKED IMMIGRATION AND
LEAVING OFFICE WITH A 28%
APPROVAL RATING IS PRETTY GOOD.
BY THE WAY, GEORGE W. BUSH,
GOD BLESS THEM, HIM, GREAT GUY,
HE DIDN'T VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP,
SO I FRANKLY DON'T CARE WHAT HE
HAS TO SAY ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
FOR EIGHT YEARS GEORGE W. BUSH,
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE G.O.P.,
WAS MUTE DURING THE TYRANNY OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND NOW
LIKE OLD FAITHFUL HE SPOUTS OFF
AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO BASH
PRESIDENT TRUMP EITHER OFF THE
RECORD OR ON THE RECORD.
RESISTANCE IS NOT PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND REPEATING THE
FAILED POLICIES OF THE PAST IS
GETTING US NOWHERE.
MY MESSAGE TO THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF BOTH PARTIES.
WE'VE TRIED YOUR EXPERT WAYS FOR
DECADES.
IT LED TO THE RISE OF COMMUNIST
CHINA, WHICH IS NOW POISED -- WE
DON'T TURN THINGS AROUND, TO BE
THE DOMINANT ECONOMIC AND
MILITARY POWER IN THE WORLD.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP, SOMETIMES
IT FEELS LIKE HE'S DOING IT ALL
BY HIMSELF, IS TRYING TO
CONFRONT THAT THREAT AND TURN IT
AROUND BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE.
THE GLOBALIST CRITICS OUT THERE
DON'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT WITH
THE FREEDOM OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WHETHER IT WILL BE
JEOPARDIZED, OUR ABILITY TO
CHART OUR OWN DESTINY, OUR OWN
COURSE THE WAY THAT DONALD TRUMP
FRANKLY SEES IT.
THE 2016 ELECTION RESULTS IN
THOSE BATTLEGROUND STATES SHOWED
THAT THE HEARTLAND WAS NOT READY
TO STATE ITS FREEDOM TO THE GODS
OF GLOBALISM.
THOSE PEOPLE EMPOWERED THE
PRESIDENT TO PROTECT THEIR
LIBERTY AND RESTORE THEIR
ECONOMIC INDEPENDENCE AND THAT'S